all right
questions for jalen
questions happy chinese
sorry stating the obvious um
how did you guys lose og in the corner
did you lose him
i guess because he was wide open right
uh
i guess it was a miscommunication hit a
tough shot to win the game
it's tough um it's tough that's the one
that we definitely
wish we could have back
did you move on yeah it felt like
a pretty big gut punch just watching how
are you guys feeling right now
uh we got to move on again to game four
um
i guess that's the focus now i'm moving
on can't nothing nobody do about it
okay nothing you know so we just got to
move on
it's tough but you know that's the
playoffs
we watched the two games before
yesterday where
the endings were you know crazy and uh
we got to be better at the end of the
game
question in person gary washburn
um on the on the final play it seemed
like you
kind of shaded toward gasol then when
you saw the pass he
kind of screamed you i mean how tough
was that when you're just probably a
step away
from or half a step away from maybe
probably getting a piece of that
uh just uh it's just a miscommunication
uh that's really all what happened
um at the end of the day you know
we just got to be better as a unit you
know
regardless of what we was in you know we
had to guard the three-point line
so that was just a [ __ ] disgrace
at the end of the game that was just
terrible
you know no way we should have lost that
game
you know i take responsibility for that
not just that play but
you know a lot of the plays before it
happens it's the nba playoffs
either you you know let it let them gain
momentum or you come back and be ready
to play next game
tim bontes jalen uh
what was going what was going through
your mind as kimbo was double-teamed out
there on the perimeter and then
just what did you think of that play he
was able to make getting in the lane and
dropped it down to tice
that was a great play uh you know he did
his job he drew two
and uh found an open man put us up too
was a big play for us point five one
o'clock we just needed one stop
to win the [ __ ] game and we and we
ended up losing
but you know you move on great play by
kimba
we gotta be ready for game four jake
king
go ahead jay
all right julio nilevis lanza
hey jalen um i just spoke to og and obi
about the shot um and it seems like the
raptors now they kind of like build
their confidence even more now
do you guys feel like asked this shot it
was kind of like a wake-up call for them
and um are you guys going to pretty much
um have more expectation about the
raptors now since they're
there's a championship you know they won
the champions league last year sorry
they're a good team they're the
defending champs we knew that wasn't
going to go down
without a fight so we got to be ready to
uh
to throw our next punch that's it you
know they responded
they got they they made a remarkable
play
at the end of the game you know so
fight continues get ready for game four
all right we'll circle back last
question jay king
jalen you you said you took
responsibility for that last play
what do you think you should have done
differently and with the gasal situation
what's the calculation between stopping
him and then getting out to og
is this a miscommunication uh you know
the coverage that we was in
you know um
that's it that's all that's all that
really is uh they made a remarkable play
at the end you know oh he snuck along
the baseline
no uh and we just got to communicate
better
i said as a unit you know that can't
happen you know
uh we were matched up and og snuck along
the baseline didn't
didn't recognize him early enough and he
got a wide open look
we got to be better than that we got to
communicate better and
you know just me being you know four
years in i got to be better
you know can't give up a three at the
end of the game
you know they made a remarkable shot
still um but
that's a it's a it's a [ __ ] disgrace
it's terrible
no excuse for at all you know what i
mean it was
ridiculous you know so can't take your
foot off the gas at all
we got to be ready to play game four
we'll wrap it up right there thanks
jalen